yo it's crazy because like what you just
said is uh like you've been
like you you've been to jail multiple
times and then in 2013 you finally
kind of was like okay yeah i feel like a
lot of a lot of like i have cousins who
have been in and out of jail nonstop
their whole life right and it's like
a lot of it it's hard to get someone to
really understand why they they're in
that position over and over again a lot
of it has to do with the people you
surround yourself with
yeah the circumstances you choose to be
around you know what i'm saying yeah
cause after a while they think your ass
dumb they'd be like man this [ __ ]
stupid this [ __ ] like jail or something
why this [ __ ] keep going back yeah like
what what
i don't understand i would ask you like
what is some advice you give somebody
who has that problem because there are
people who are good people who
just keep getting wrapped up in you know
that the cycle of just
going in and out of jail every couple of
years you know what i'm saying to be
honest
to be honest with [ __ ] man like on
some real [ __ ]
the system is set up for a [ __ ] to stay
in there to go back you put what i'm
saying
like they be pulling 15 year olds over
you know what i'm saying fresh
out of school because they want you on
probation early they want to get your
own paperwork get your own probation
insurance then they can just [ __ ] you
over every time
for your rights so then when you do go
to jail
uh and you get out and you're still on
probation or you're on parole
any little thing that you do violations
yeah i could be chilling with my family
member and this [ __ ] on probation of
parole
you but you can't be affiliated with
those kind of people bro yeah so that
[ __ ] right there
have your ass back fast yeah i feel like
that's the biggest loophole is like
especially if you're from where you're
from it's like yo so you're telling me i
can't be around my
my cousins or yeah you know anybody
that's you know what i'm saying
affiliate but that's damn near
whole l.a oh you can't live in a gang
neighborhood what do you want me to do
the whole l.a right right right right
grandmom standing somebody hood
auntie standing somebody huh mom
standing in somebody hood you feel i'm
saying